[Music]
working on lately I'm actually writing
and directing a lot I wrote and directed
a short film in December that'll be
coming out next month and I'm working on
a feature to shoot in so ever and I
gotta ask you big news for your old
co-star ariana grande yeah ariana is now
engaged to Pete Davidson that have you
heard the news yes of course it's
everywhere I'm super proud of her and
excited for her I hope that she is super
happy are you shocked by how quickly
they got engaged
I'm definitely it's very best but they
seem like they're great fit he's totally
from what I know of her he seems like
exactly a good person for yeah when you
worked with her I mean what kind of guy
was she going for does he fit the bill
tattoos she always likes the tattoos and
he was and humor of course yeah yeah
are you expecting an invite to that
wedding better a better kill the last
time you talked to Ariana um we could go
we were texting what do you guys still
talk about I mean this is so cute oh
just checking in just little check-ins
what did you say to her when you first
heard about the engagement news uh
congratulations with like emoji she
seemed happier than you've ever seen her
um well I mean through text so how can
you how can you really tell right when
was the last time imagine I mean it's
it's a great life event of course who
wouldn't be super happy when was the
last time you actually like saw her hung
out with her I think it was probably a
year yeah we were we were eating pizza
and talking about Harry Potter which
makes sense
[Music]